[Music]
slowly but surely the movie business is
getting back on track and in addition to
a number of top class films such as
spider-man and dune which will be out
this year we would like to take a look
at some of the most anticipated movies
of 2022
included rmcu blockbusters and exciting
video game adaption and hard-hitting
action so sit back and enjoy part 1 of
our most anticipated movies of 2022
2022 will start off with a sequel to a
horror classic scream 5.
consistent with its name the movie is
supposed to directly follow stream 4
from 2011.
in front of and behind the camera the
direction leans more towards a reboot
which of course has a lot to do with the
passing of wes craven the creator of the
film series
with david arquette we will at least see
one really familiar face again as the 49
year old has embodied dooley rally as
the sheriff of woodsborough in every
single scream film so far
also said to be back rnf campbell is
sidney prescott courtney cox's gail
weathers and roger l jackson as the
voice of ghost face
the directory cast will feature two
directors at once namely tyla gillett
and matt bettinelli alpin among other
projects the two are known for directing
the 2019 thriller ready or not
they themselves say wes craven inspired
and influenced them as fans and they are
very honored to continue the lives work
of the director who sadly passed away in
2015.
in terms of content we don't know all
that much yet considering the ones
returning and a couple of new faces it
probably amounts to a normal sequel to
part 4 though therefore the old gang
might meet again to finally put an end
to the masked man after he terrorizes a
few new victims we are definitely
looking forward to the horror slasher
which is scheduled for release on
january 14
2022 as our second blockbuster of the
month of january we present morbius the
upcoming film is along with venom and
venom 2 the third movie from the
so-called sony spider-man universe and
revolves around the title anti-hero dr
michael morbius the brilliant biochemist
suffers from a difficult to cure blood
disease which he tries to treat himself
needless to say this goes horribly wrong
and so he contracts a form of vampirism
which in the end is arguably even worse
than the original disease itself
the 49 year old multi-talent jared leto
will be seen in the leading role joining
him in front of the camera will be good
omen star adria jonah as the
protagonist's partner and doctor who
actor matt smith who will be embodying
the marvel character laksha's crown also
starring our churnable actor jared
harris along with tyrese gibson who will
play an fbi agent as well as michael
keaton who will be seen as the villain
adrian toombs further it will be
exciting to see whether and how the film
will tie in with venom 2 which is said
in the same universe sony's morbius will
be released in theories on january 28
2022
in february there will be the release of
the video game adaption uncharted the
focus is on nathan drake who's a
descendant of the renowned seafarer sir
francis drake on his daring expeditions
which can be experienced in four parts
on the playstation so far he regularly
ends up in the most remote places on a
planet this time he sets off in search
of the legendary city of gold el dorado
according to his research it is supposed
to be somewhere in south america and so
the still young explorer in the film
sets off with the journalist and his
mentor victor sullivan in search of the
treasure of course the three are not
alone during their quest and so they
have to compete against other treasure
hunters mercenaries and pirates
in the role of the young nathan drake we
get to see tom holland while fellow
actor mark wahlberg plays a young sully
especially the latter does not really
raise a lot of excitement in the
community given that wahlberg hardly
resembles his video game role model in
the pictures published so far
which might be mainly due to the lack of
the distinctive mustache however the
beard can still be hoped for after all
we're talking about an origin story here
and on instagram wahlberg can indeed be
seen with a typical facial hair you can
convince yourself of the final result in
theaters from february 11 2022
just over three weeks after uncharted
the next movie will then be the batman
in march
set in the 1990s the noir narrative will
pay special attention to batman's
detective skills and will be a
standalone story with no connection to
the dceu much like joker was in 2019
the dark knight solo adventure will be
directed by mad reefs while hollywood
star robert pattinson will assume the
lead role
the now 7th movie batman was not well
received from the start
for many the 35 year old is still too
much associated with the teen saga
twilight and this despite the fact that
in recent years he has clearly
emancipated himself from his previous
parts with serious roles such as in
tanit or the lighthouse
along with pattonson we will also see
performances by numerous villains
including paul dano as the riddler zoe
kravitz as an earlier version of
catwoman colin pharrell as the penguin
and john terturo as carmine falcone
as you can see batman will be very busy
in the upcoming film he can of course
also hope for active support from two
mates namely commissioner james gordon
and his benevolent butler alfred
pennyworth
whether the dark knight can't stand up
to his adversaries is something we will
be able to find out as of march 4th 2022
march will continue to be exciting
thanks to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
the sequel to the 2016 blockbuster will
as the name suggests take a closer look
at the concept of multiverses after this
was already opened up at the end of the
loki series
the cast is truly gigantic and can
almost compete with the lineup of an
avengers movie it'll feature benedict
cumberbatch as dr steven strange
benedict wong as a loyal companion wong
rachel adams is dr christine palmer chew
talashi for as the main villain carl
mordo elizabeth olsen won the maximum of
aka scarlet witch and last but not least
social gomes who makes her mcu debut as
the young superhero america chavez
further rumors suggest appearances by
tom hiddleston as loki bruce campbell
and probably one of the three spider-man
appearing in norway home meaning either
tom holland toby maguire or andrew
garfield obviously other well-known
stars may also feature in the film as
they might still be kept secret behind
the camera sam raimi is in charge of
directing after the original director
scott derrickson backed out and is now
acting as executive producer doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
will be released in news theaters on
march 25th 2022
the month of april brings another two
top class films the first is sonic the
hedgehog 2. the sequel revolves around
the new life of the blue hedgehog who
has now found a new home in green hills
among his friends tom and maddie
the threat of dr robotnik's return seems
distant after sonic banished him to a
mushroom planet
just as maddie and tom are on holiday
the villain makes a comeback but he's
not alone
teamed up with knuckles with whom sonic
is not buddies here yet robotnik embarks
on a quest to find a fabled emerald that
holds the power of either destroying or
building entire
civilizations in order to prevent this
incredibly valuable artifact from
falling to the hands of the antagonist
sonny and his friend tails also set out
to find the emerald
as was announced a short time ago idris
elbow will dub the red echidna it goes
without saying that ben swords will once
again be voicing the blue hedgehog while
james marston and tikka sumter will be
back in front of the camera as tom and
maddie together with jim carrey as dr
robotnik
the release of sonic the hedgehog 2 is
scheduled for april 8 2022
marvel's thor franchise has been
thrilling fans around the globe for over
a decade the witty god of thunder will
return to the big screen again next year
for what is now his fourth movie
after the pandemic upset the plans to
start filming in 2020 the time was right
to begin shooting thor love and thunder
in australia at the start of this year
the plot centers on the one hand on thor
himself as he loses the ability to lift
mjolnir
however the focus will be more on
another character namely dr jane foster
mighty thor as she is also called is
worthy of lifting thor's hammer and
henceforth becomes the mighty goddess of
thunder
in principle the two have similar powers
but it is said that there will be some
subtle differences as well
in front of the camera we can look
forward to chris hemsworth as thor
natalie portman as jane foster tessa
thompson as valkyrie and christian bale
as gore the god butcher among many other
familiar faces the release date of thor
love and thunder is set for may 6 2022
the action in john week 4 promises to be
very intense
you don't need to be a clairvoyant to
suspect that this time around we'll be
dealing with a rather angry john wick he
and the bowery king are out for revenge
against the high table the continental
and of course his manager winston
featured on screen will be keanu reeves
as john wick lawrence fishburne is the
bowery king
ian mcshane as winston and lance reddick
as the concierge charon one newcomer is
japanese british pop star arena savayama
who like martial arts legends donnie yen
and scott atkins is expected to take on
an unspecified role likewise joining the
cast in recent weeks and months have
been marco zero hiroyuki zanada chemier
anderson clancy brown and bill skosgod
this is absolutely a cast to be excited
about
john wick chapter 4 will be released on
may 27 2022 in the united states
in june we can look forward to the
conclusion of an extremely successful
film series with the release of jurassic
world dominion the hype is huge although
the date of the release is still several
months in the future one contributing
element is certainly the return of some
of the actors from the 1993 original as
laura dern jeff goldblum and sam neal
will be seen together on the big screen
for the first time in years other
returning actors who will be seen
alongside chris pratt and the like
include bd wong as dr henry wu justice
smith as franklin webb and omar sais
barry samban director colin trevorrow
further revealed that the 1993 stars
will have about as much screen time as
those in the jurassic world trilogy thus
nostalgic should get their money's worth
not much is known about this story yet
now that macy lockwood has released all
the dinosaurs there are many
possibilities as to which direction
jurassic world dominion could take
is it more in terms of coexistence
between humans and dinosaurs or are the
prehistoric creatures a massive threat
to humanity after all
should this be the case
how will the beasts be dealt with
jurassic world dominion will hit cinemas
on june 10 2022
well that's it for the first part of the
movies we are most looking forward to in
2022 did you enjoy the video then please
subscribe and activate the notification
bell to ensure that you don't miss the
second part of our most anticipated
movies of 2022 take care see you next
time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]